do you guys think body count matters
yes yes 100 is this for both genders
yeah uh for women let's say for women
and then the firm i do women than men so
okay oh not for men no no matters for
god women yes
men
not so much
okay
no neither
okay
i don't think it
i think it only matters
how it's put out there because somebody
a woman can have a high body count
nobody knows about it she carries
herself or even men will know about it
and she carries herself different
remember treats are different
but you can have somebody without high
body care not even as high as that
woman's body care and it's all out there
for everyone to see it's all over the
internet
then it matters because you must know
women that have got high body cats you
still respect them because the way they
carry themselves and normally it's the
older woman not the younger woman
because there's lots of older women out
there with high body cats and people
still respect them they're the aunties
they're the grandmas
but then you get the young women there
and they got a high body can
and it's like a badge of honor
wouldn't you say it makes you less
valuable to men though the more men you
sleep with
yeah yeah women don't know that because
they're always trying to get that better
man
what women don't know that women
definitely know that well no no it's
it's like a coke if they did why would
we sleep in the summer
i'll just buddy
yeah i'll just um just a quick stat only
30
of
wait um
when a woman gets married and she's a
virgin she has an 80 chance of a happy
marriage if she slept with more than
five people it drops to thirty percent
ah wow
that means i'm at two percent
what did you do
did you know it's gonna be i've gotta be
at two percent or something like that
yeah and it does it's not like the end
all it's not saying like every single
girl that slept around like that's her
fate but
it's i think to say that like sleeping
around has a good
is good for women is kind of a lie that
feminism teaches go ahead i think it's
bad for women
i think it's bad for both but more so
for women because
with men there's a pride attached to it
with women there's a stigma attached to
it
so i think nowadays the women are trying
to turn that stigma into pride and it's
not working
that's where the modern women get lost
because that stigma of having a high
body count is no longer there they're
wearing it with pride i think it also
like from a male point of view it also
depends on
the people she slept with to a point as
well because if for example say you live
in one of those areas and a lot of
people know each other
okay one of men's biggest i don't want
to say nightmares but hang ups is
bumping into another guy
like oh i know your girl like i know
her
sorry i think yeah you go actually the
point so
body con uh for men
so when you're approaching a girl
because it actually touching your
confidence so science you know that your
women actually slept with 10 20 other
men
you like losing confidence
and your like worry your first word is
like you know
get to know
yeah you don't exactly
left with
so it's about you not about us well but
if you give something away for free it's
not valuable
so if you if you feel free
if you're giving if you're giving it to
a lot of people it's not valuable so why
that doesn't like go
off of way right because because men and
women are different women are born with
value where men have men have to create
their values so for you to want to sleep
with a guy he's got to be tall he's got
to be good looking he's got to have a
job like he has to do things one out of
three men under 30 are virgins or
haven't had sex in the past year and
women are sleeping with five to twenty
percent of guys so the reason like women
hate man is cuz we're all sleeping with
the same ones
i'm not agreeing about this honestly um
because
the fact you as he said the fact you
slept with multiple men or whatever how
many they are doesn't really it depends
like was you actually in a relationship
with him
oh it was just occasional thing you know
and i also accept occasional stuff like
because
you know like if you match
someone and you you know you just want
to enjoy your day there's nothing wrong
with that and that's honestly no one
allowed her men to tell me are less
vulnerable than someone else that had
sex just once
well it's not it's like it's not who is
my body gonna be the same body
and
myself gonna be the same person after 10
20 men it wouldn't change it's not it's
not anything about who you are as a
person but it's what men value so you
can't so so you can't go up to guys and
say don't value this because it's what
they want so that's like me selling a
car and going up to the people that want
to buy a car and say like this car and
they say no i don't want to buy that car
because it's got too many miles and
you're saying well you should like cars
with high miles
with the women honestly we're talking
about completely different
so women can't get no title like that
because when she's saying that nobody's
gonna know you have about 30 men you're
gonna be as loose as hell the men know
and like the thing is you know and at
the end of the day if a woman sleeps
with loads of men she's a she's a [ __ ]
every man man sleeps with loads of women
he's a stud yeah so that goes to show
from the beginning and that's i'm sorry
you
we didn't make that rule as well no but
but that's the way it is yeah if that's
the way it is
and at the end of the day right men
can have loads of sex and it's always
going to be like women
yeah so
that's the only way i can put it you're
going to you're going to know
you can't say no it's my body what's
going on because
you're going to be no amount of lime and
salt can help you yeah because you get
trauma from everyone
like you can't you can't say like a very
okay that that girl that came in earlier
you could tell she hadn't slept with a
lot of people because she was just so
nice and like like you can like feel it
on a girl right because they're not
they're not like traumatized because if
you sleep with 20 30 40 guys the odds
that one is gonna have hurt you is like
higher and higher and higher like how do
you go through that many guys and none
hurt you come on yeah none you can't you
kind of unscathed come on no it's not
about sex it's not i mean a man doesn't
argue just because you having sex with
him he argued for a lot of other reasons
and doesn't matter
this sex like it's not about sex
he actually asks you when he does
something wrong
i don't think it does something wrong in
bad it can do something wrong you know
in any other occasion actually probably
they're going to be
good in bed and then probably doing
but that's but that's like a masculine
trait is not being able to bond with men
through sex because women tend to bond
with men through sex unless they've
slept with a lot of people then they
don't why we don't just think about that
our women can enjoy sex as a man like
like you can imagine catching feelings
no matter what
quick just around guys in the room i'm
just asking have you ever slept with a
girl that said it was casual and then
she caught feelings yes yes um yes
have you ever slept with a girl that
casually and then she caught feelings
yeah
do i don't know your name but yes yes
yeah give me yes or no yeah yeah okay
so four random guys are in this room all
saying this yeah what about the opposite
why do you ask me what do you mean if i
stop any kind of you know relationship
with them because we weren't talking
because we weren't talking about you we
were talking about the men yeah
me as a woman no me as alessandra like
if that can happen for a man it's tough
to see someone
because it was catching feeling that can
happen also with a man the only thing is
um that men usually they just don't say
when they catch him feeling because they
feel
like you know we it's the stereotype of
men
so it's not allowed to say yeah i'm
falling in love just i've been sexing
with it with you so he wouldn't say that
he wouldn't say that no but like pearl
said we don't really there's always
going to be exceptions to the rule but
the reality is it doesn't work both ways
and listen if a man catches feelings for
a woman he's with that woman forever yes
he's going to stick with her
and that's the difference if a woman if
a woman catches feelings she's gonna
chase that man even though it's a
one-night stand but for monkey's
feelings then that's his woman
that is his woman simple as that because
men hold men hold access or women are in
control of sex men are in control of
relationships correct so again like it's
not it's not fun but it's just like how
the world is like there are double
standards for men and for women we're
different we don't operate the same way
and like guys are repulsed by girls that
have slept around
women sleep with who they want men sleep
with who let them
yes point of view sucks
[Music]
so question for the guys how many bodies
is too many bodies
let's put a number to it depends on the
age
okay let's say so the average age the
average age of first marriage in the uk
is 31. okay what would you how many
bodies is too many bodies for a 31 year
old jeez hey i'm black your firstborn
over double figures over double so 10 10
10 10 and up okay
20 i'll give a little yeah
now we've got really it's 20 22 yeah
nice man brother you're being nice you
you wouldn't want to hear 20 and you're
right i agree with 20 i think 20. so you
would never lose you would marry a woman
with 20 bodies
would i marry a woman with 20 bodies
no
would you okay okay okay okay okay that
was too much what's the minimum
okay would you let me just ask the
question a different way would you marry
a girl with 10 bodies yes or no yes
would you marry 10 yeah yeah
well yeah what about you okay would you
marry a girl with 15 bodies yes or no
potentially potentially yeah yeah
i think 15 is the max for me okay 20. no
no it's just getting sticky
yeah
okay yes yes okay so
20 no no 15 is the max 15 is the max
okay now what percent of women that are
31 do you think have less than 15 bodies
about five percent
about twenty percent twenty percent i
know i'm gonna ask the women this too
go ahead twenty five percent twenty five
percent what do you think what percent
of women that are thirty one have less
than fifteen bodies have less than yeah
uh just about yeah also say your name
your agent where you're from
i'm christina from hackney i'm 35. okay
welcome to the show
i don't know
wait come back to me it's okay what
percent of women do you think have less
than 15 bodies at 31
10 percent ten percent i'll say fifty
fifty i don't even i'm just totally
shocked when you think sixteen is a
legal age you're everybody's thinking
that forty fourteen
and you're thinking fifteen that's like
that's that's more than one a year
mm-hmm wow so what are you
is that you're shy like that's a lot or
a little that's a lot yeah
in like 14 years 15
yeah
wow and that's like going that's what's
going on now
yeah yeah that's mostly one that's not
relationship that's just like shagging
didn't it well that's that's because
modern women are side checks because
because again it's a it's a
no no because remember it's a smaller
and smaller percentage of men that are
sleeping with all the girls so if you
look at dating app data like women only
swipe right like five percent of the
time up to you know ten fifteen percent
that's high so women are and the number
one people way that people meet is
online dating
and so women are side chicks because
they're all sleeping with the same guys
because if you want a guy that's over
six foot that's fifteen percent of men
you waving well i am
he's single he said you wanna be if you
wanna be one of the girls
and so um yeah so like modern women are
side chicks because that's disgusting
it's a small percentage of men that are
sleeping with all the girls i'm just
saying one out of three men under 30 or
either virgins or haven't had sex in the
past year
so like so that indicates the trend
which is less and less and less and like
the big frustration that i hear from men
is basically that girls get ran through
by like the guys they actually want in
their 20s and then they hit like 30 and
then they're like please take me and
then they finally come around to the
like guys in their friend zone basically
at like 30.
sounds about right is that something
you've seen too the oldest one here
would you say that's a valid complaint
yeah i mean when they get older they
always try and look back at what they
could have had
but by then it's too late because
they've got loads of kids behind them
and
weird baby fathers and
i mean weird habits and
i'm just shocked about the 15. the 15.
what what did you think
okay okay at 30 how many how many what
do you think most women had from your
generation
i think you just stuck with the same
person for a couple of years
but
so you would have said like five by the
end of thirty but fifty yeah because the
thing is like the girls are sleeping
with that small percentage of guys right
so those guys aren't going to stick with
a girl for a couple of years because so
with the girls but because the thing is
like guys will sleep with anything so a
guy that's an eight nine or ten will
sleep with a four five or six even if
he's never seen it been seen in public
with her ever out there stop having sex
close your legs don't do it it's not
good
and so and so it's like uh
that is disgusting
i'm thinking
15 partners in 14 years
yeah
do you think that's a lot
that's not a lot in today's generation
it's not a lot it's a i will say it's a
different time yeah it's a different
time yeah one a year no no no no we
ain't doing that no more i'll take back
my hot girl decade because that was
nothing because i could have had like
them 15 men in a whole decade let alone
oh yeah it's more like like you know how
you guys slept together for a couple
years it's like a couple of months
nowadays
men need to be preserving this verb and
this this
well why would they when when they have
like that small percentage of men if
they have women on a silver platter why
would they these are pride in who they
joke
why
because
listen right you you wanna if you're
gonna go there sleep with a girl make
sure you're not number three number four
you'd only be number nine number ten
number 11 number 12 number 15
because then you're you're 15.
imagine if you're number 15 honestly
honestly and you heard and you heard the
panel right the majority by 31 have
probably slept with more
that's the question they were saying the
other day that women when the girls said
oh we can lie about it
if you have 15 by the end of by the age
of course you're going to want to lie
she was like oh what if they don't know
about the body count what if you lie
about it my guys know
oh my god do you think a man should feel
shame if he knows he's the 15th guy to
have had sex with
yeah you don't know who's been there
before you vomit in that no man can i
try and put it into retrospect and
essentially if a guy's the 15th guy here
he's going in knowing
i'm not staying
i'm leaving straight after so
whoever's number 16 whoever's number 17
it is what it is yeah and then it will
get to someone who's like number 30 and
they're like
i'll wife it
and it's like that person is the one
that lost and everyone else got it for
well
i will say something on the other end
though a lot of guys do cap because
they'll come on these shows and they'll
say they wouldn't wipe a girl over a
certain account
and i know who they're dating
and i'm like
i'm not
i'm just kidding
i've definitely liked girls who have had
high body counts i have but how did you
know they had did you ask them well they
they happen to be honest with me and i
take their word for it because it's not
a number that you would just openly want
to say
but
you know
it's always in my mind as much as i like
what they say what number
i just don't know what number it was a
ballpark figure oh
right
how do you lose count yeah it was a
ballpark figure so then so add add 20 on
to whatever she's saying
it was a ballpark figure of close to
three figures oh
shut up
wait sorry
okay
because wow
she's taking a chance having a hot girl
so much
decades for a whole decade crazy hot
girl that's like a that's a lot it's
like a yeah but you say you like her i
did like her
before you found out the body count no
no i knew it i knew it you know what i
think i think my
i think you just thought right what
about if my friend they're gonna get to
know that that's the thing
you can't really control who you like or
who you fall for but you can control how
you deal with the situation or how you
operate or how you choose to move
forward i've got questions
when you found out about the body count
were you repulsed
um
i wouldn't say repulse no because i just
don't really get that surprised in this
day and age like you know three figures
yeah i know did you hit it
did you go there no why not
because it it never came about what ever
come about but you're still gone with
the three figures yeah yeah
yeah
i mean men can't undo their biology
they're biologically predispositioned to
want to spread their seed but they're
also biologically predispositioned to
want to want to ensure paternity so like
historically if a girl slept around they
don't know if the kid she's having is
his and that even still happens nowadays
like you see videos all the time where
this dude that's been raising a kid for
10 years finds out this kid is in heads
and girls can do that legally there's no
ramification that's a crazy life where
if guys don't play child support they go
to jail but a girl can trap a guy and
crazy so mori made a whole career off
that real [ __ ] yeah and so like guys
can't undo how they feel about it
i don't think like that automatically if
she
has a high body count and if she is in a
relationship she actually you know love
the men she's been with she's gonna
sleep automatically with someone else so
easily that doesn't honestly
we should like distinguish between when
you single are you free to do whatever
you wish and when you are in our
relationship so it doesn't mean you're
going to be not loyal
do you know what i mean like more it's
more likely your habits are who you are
why you need to label someone just
because yeah it's based on yours no it's
based on your actions so same for men so
i would say men can actually is actually
allowed to have high body count so what
i what i supposed to think if i'm
actually going to marry the man they
gonna cheat on me
like women but women don't women women
don't care because that's like i'm i'm a
woman and i can't guys no no so women
women don't care you don't see girls
lining up to date drake and saying oh no
his body counts too high how will i get
like no no
but but the opposite of that brittany
grant grayner griner whatever her name
is like guys are like oh jesus christ oh
no no no no yeah because brittany and
she's beautiful but brittany reynolds
your habits like make up who you are so
if you've been doing something for a
decade how like just like if a guy
cheated on every single girl before you
he's probably going to cheat on you too
duh
personally for me if if a guy's body
count is like the three figures i'd be
just as disgusted don't matter if he's
drake chris but i don't care i'd be
repulsed to be honest
if he's 50 depending on how old he is
again i'd still feel a bit icky is it oh
yeah no you're gonna be icky would you
want to marry a virgin
i wouldn't mind you wouldn't mind
marrying a virgin you'd want to like
tell him what to do
i wouldn't mind because it's not
it's not an issue for me if he ticks
every single box and then it turns out
he's a virgin
to me i wouldn't i wouldn't be fast
could you name could you name five of
your boxes
name five of my boxes
so
ambitious
god fearing like prayerful um
loyal as well
funny sort of sense of humor
and
i can't think of a fifth one when you
say ambitious is there a dollar amount
no ambitious like driven wanting
something for himself and not just so if
he's making how old are you so you're 31
35 35 how old would you date
the oldest i would they yeah
probably 40. so if he's 40 and he still
makes 30 000
i don't know the conversion like thirty
thousand us dollars which would be like
twenty twenty like twenty thousand um
twenty thousand pounds would you be cool
with that he's forty seven time to get
there
if he's if he's trying to get somewhere
and he's not just what if he gets what
if he gets nowhere
because i'd i'd sense that he's not
ambitious and it would put me off right
but i think like a lot of times it's
kind of disingenuous to guys because
girls will say there's no price but you
have one in your head and there is a
price he either has to be working
towards that like towards it or there
but if he doesn't get there within a
certain amount of time your ghost you're
gone no but
you can't really put a time frame on i'm
giving you a time to become successful
but no i'm saying and you might not know
everyone to want to get there and
actively trying to get there does that
make sense
you might not know it like like you
might not have thought about it but like
in some level you're not going to date a
bum forever so if if he's i wouldn't
have if he's a bum
and he's not ambitious i wouldn't be
attracted to you
yeah but i'm saying there's a there's a
doll there's a minimum dollar
so
okay would you date a guy that's
homeless with no job i wouldn't meet a
guy that's homeless in my job where
would i meet you you pass them every day
but why would i approach you probably
gonna even approach me or how would that
work right but i'm saying you there's a
minimum requirement you have
not just related to it like
is that a bad thing no it's not a bad
thing i don't think i don't think we
should date bombs what i'm saying like
you're avoiding the question what was
the question
what's the minimum amount of money you
need a guy to make
i don't know more than me i don't know
it's the same as me or more okay what's
roughly you don't have to
i don't want to say my how much i make
but the same as me or more thus you
can't make less than you right basically
yeah okay why not well i'm not saying he
can't but i would prefer i'm saying what
i prefer is if he was the same level as
me or making more if he's making less a
bit less and actively trying to
progress within his career then there's
nothing wrong with that he can't just
out something he said about the boxes
are your boxes and it was the virgin
you said you take on a virgin virgin
wasn't in the book
no she said she said
what are your boxes when he said about
yeah she no woman ever says
if
sex
was a man wouldn't that be one of your
boxes
you know you said that if he was a ver
and he ticked your boxes yeah as a man
wouldn't sex be one of your top boxes
i'm just asking as in would i marry a
virgin
no are you getting sick
you know you said every man every woman
takes all your boxes right isn't sex one
of your boxes
um
do you think did you live
could you have a happy relationship
without having that box sticks without
having sex or without having good sex
good sex
yeah i could still have a
pretty successful relationship not me
yeah so youtube you have never hesitated
i don't believe you yeah i mean look i
know that's one of my main boxes i don't
know because i'm saying everybody's
talking about oh i want to be nicer
compatible
but you won't know that until you have
sex with him that's why
that's why when women say they want to
have a virgin to me
i teach you know
because i ain't got time if i'm a virgin
he's a virgin fine but i am not gonna go
and pick up a virgin
f sex is one of my boxes and sex is one
of my boxes it should be a man's box too
because if you're not getting good sex
from your woman go elsewhere safely for
women i'm sorry but how could that's why
they've got sexless marriages out there
yes how can you be having like you be oh
yeah i'm happy well sex is not one of my
boxes she knows that sex at one of your
boxes and when the sex is gone what are
you going to do then say oh but i like
her personality
i have a question do you think it's fair
for women to expect monogamy from men if
they gave their best years to another
man
[Laughter]
andy you want to start
he's a little nervous
no give your best to the one you got and
if you can't give him your best and he's
going elsewhere
then you can't blame him
i'm sorry but like i said before no man
no man no woman should probably bad sex
and if a man is having bad sex it's the
woman's fault
it's the woman's fault because if you
get a man a male virgin and a woman
he's gonna have bad sex anyway she's
gonna teach him rubbish just to keep him
down there but if you get a man who's
had lots of sex and a virgin he's gonna
teach everything he knows to make sure
that she can perform properly
so as far as i'm concerned if you are
with somebody and you're not getting
good sex from them
i'm not talking about making enough
because women audiences making up making
up that's the little christmas birthdays
whatever men is gonna have sex after sex
saying god
get rid because i'm sorry but there's
too many men that they're having sexist
relationships and it's wrong
all these feelings about oh i want that
personality i want this and that why
doesn't that work the other way you said
that the man can teach the virgin woman
how to have good sex but why can't the
woman who's had a lot of sex teach the
virgin how to have this why is it not
well i just i just think if women were
lined up for virgins then one out of
three men wouldn't be virgins
wait say again if women were lined up to
date virgins if that was true then one
out of three men wouldn't be virgins
i don't get it because they're actually
the male virgins
oh okay one out of three men under 30
haven't had sex in the past year or are
virgins one out of every three men
so like if women wanted virgins they're
there
but how would you know
i still don't care and that falls into
that how much confident she was sorry
say that she was talking about earlier
with a man approaching you nobody was
talking earlier and he mentioned
confidence that confidence comes from
experience with women over time so that
same confident guy you want to approach
you he's not going to get that
confidence unless he's had that previous
experience including sexual
so
you won this guy with this low body
count that's not the same sort of guy
confidence like i don't think it's like
just related to sex obviously yeah if
you had had you know multiple women like
you had a lot of experience you're
probably going to be a tiny bit more
confident
but i think like you know how do you
acting by this kind of even you know
inside you or you have it or not like
it's not really
about how many directions the men can
bring it at you a man can bring out a
woman but how often does a woman bring
it out of a man is that because you're
speaking from a woman's perspective so
you wouldn't know women so i can only
speak from oh i had men so i i got male
friends most i say 99 of my friend and
male
they're not getting enough sex
and they're not getting enough sex how
they want it where they want it whenever
they want it and it's the women that are
like holding these keys to sex
like
that's why i can speak from a woman
because there's men out there you can as
a woman that's had ex-partners you can
look at your partners and see where the
women have done them wrong
you can know because the women teaching
them the women are so quick to open
their legs but not their mouth to say
excuse me but mate but what you doing
down there that's wrong fix up or this
is how you're supposed to do it but
there's too many men there's too many
women out there now having bad sex
because of the men's previous partners
not teaching them properly
[Music]
interesting that's not well i guess i
guess as a girl but how do you know it's
bad you must have a lot to compete like
peter nice baths
not running and i'm not shivering
about the earthquake no i'm saying you
have to have a lot to compare it to to
know it's bad
no no you can just know how you feel
because if you go and you relax yourself
and you free up and you trust the man
that he knows what you're doing you're
gonna have good sex all the time
um okay what you want to answer the
question um i mean i personally so like
this might sound controversial but i
feel it's unrealistic to believe a man
should be with one woman
okay so i agree
that you know they shouldn't expect it
from a man but i feel like everything
comes down to control so
as a man if you decide you're going to
go into a relationship you have to
decide to control yourself and choose to
be faithful
what if your woman is a freak
what would that what would that do not
she's up for anything with you sexually
yeah you're still gonna go as well it
doesn't matter you're still gonna go
outside if you wanna go elsewhere you're
gonna go you can have the perfect woman
in the world
if you wanna cheat you cheat it doesn't
matter there's i do not believe there is
anything a woman can do to stop a man
from cheating if he wants to cheat
sorry do you agree that not all men
cheat
hold it down bro do you agree that not
all men should speak your truth
some men don't
no i'm saying not all men cheat yeah
that's fine then
one thing i can i i don't go ahead so
one thing i will say is i think men
exercise their options right so most men
women don't find them attractive and
therefore they don't have options to
exercise
and therefore they cannot cheat whereas
the top percentile of men
have options to exercise therefore they
can cheat and if the woman that is with
them
feels a type of way wants to leave
he's like okay
i'll just add a new girl to the rotation
and he's able to get a plethora of girls
because he's got the option to exercise
his will to cheat
yeah no that's fine i just i just don't
believe that all men cheat no there's a
minority that don't i i agree i think
yeah but i think you'd agree most do if
they can't yeah
yeah if they could but but most men
can't
and mostly [ __ ]
can't what most men in relationships
can't choose
um
so what about you do you think it's fair
that women expect monogamy if they gave
their best ears to another man ah no um
definitely not definitely not
what would you define as a woman's best
years go ahead okay well i'll put that
into the same sort of especially with
that particular male or man
usually her child's dad her first love
is usually that type of person
you know he's usually he's usually got
everything else out of her by the time
you've come across her whatever the
scenario is
you are getting the after bits there's
going to be memories of him be it in a
relationship sexual whatever
you know there's going to be especially
if they've got a child there's an
imprint i've seen it loads of times
you know people have broken up they've
got with someone else as soon as the kid
dad's come back in the picture
gone they're either sleeping together or
they're back together so
if a woman's had her best years with
another male
to me she she's actually his to be
perfectly honest and i found a lot of
the time that
there's that one particular guy
is there a certain age whether you would
say
in and around 30 30 ish
midfield it depends what she's kind of
done up to then okay um
but to be fair about sort of like the
mid 30ish then by that point it's like
yeah
what do you think is it fair to expect
monogamy if you've given your best years
to another man
because because it's like if van if men
value purity and youth and you don't
have that to give to him how can we
expect like monogamy when they can't
fulfill their mating strategy
is this
are you speaking like from a new
relationship or they've been together
for years and now he can cheat because
she's given her best like so so what i'm
saying is relationships are an exchange
and men and women want different things
like we want resources we want together
tall and that can protect you we want
resources protection provisioning guys
want youth purity
peace
and so if they can't fulfill their
mating strategy which is to get a girl
with low mileage that's young
why would we expect them to give to
forsake their mating strategy which is
to spread their seed
but then so is it isn't that kind of an
unfair deal for men so then if if you
then why would you stay with that person
and cheat
if
if the person if the woman's not giving
you the youth or whatever whatever
why keep her there and cheat on her when
you can just
leave and be with the youth that you
want that's my thing like i don't
understand
but i'm saying well is it fair that
women expect it over a certain age
that's the question
because you give your best years to
someone else
she's talking about going into a new
relationship yeah i know but if you go
into a new relationship and say this is
the car and the car has been used for
the last 15 years don't have a spy a
date honestly speaking like who said
that we gave our best to someone else i
don't even know my maximum or my best
probably i never done to to no one my
best because i don't know i give
honestly someone before i don't know if
i get the maximum i can i don't know
maybe i'm gonna find tomorrow man i'm
gonna give actually the best of myself
who said that i already gave to someone
else it's about what they think is the
best it's not about you because you're
not the one buying so the guy the guy i
think is the best
yes
men from the ages of 20 to 80 all think
that girls are the most attractive
around 22 to 24. okay but like this is a
man that cannot stand on his own like
honestly because
if you honestly think that he can't
stand on his own yeah because like they
actually mind about what other people
think because if you're telling me that
after like they might be shaming men for
their standards that's shame shame and
soul guilt need to be no that's just my
point of view i'm saying that i don't
even spy your day does this doesn't mean
that after because i had six-year
relationship i gave my best to someone
no
like if a man think this it means that
he's not that confident to like
get my best
it doesn't it doesn't have to think like
me i just don't want to mend the
thinking this way just give me alone do
you know what i mean i want to mend that
it comes with confidence say i'm going
to get the best of you
point like i'm not spying like just
because i'm 30 or
yeah do you think you determine what the
best years are do you think they
determine what the best years are i
think we pick each other we should we
should actually pick the best for us me
and the man also okay what do you think
i think it depends on the situation
it depends on your ages where you're
right in your life
obviously men prefer younger women so
what age ranges are we saying are their
best years i mean
it's different for i didn't say an age
so you could say 40 you could say 45 you
could say 35 you could say 30. that's i
don't i don't tell the men what to do
they're 45 on average men prefer younger
women and women prefer older yeah so i'm
guessing the man is older
so
so why wouldn't she expect monogamy like
is he going to go younger than the 40s
i'm saying okay i'm saying isn't that a
unfair deal for men because he's not
getting the things that men value
it depends on the age so say you're 50
and you're going out with a 40 year old
what would you want bro like
but the question okay so the reason i
ask this is because i think a lot of
women would have better results if they
took that off the table but they think
they're a higher value than they are
because they're they're selling the same
price they had at 22 that they that they
are asking for at 35 45 even though
they're on sale they're on discount
because you're you're not you're not
sorry
i'm saying in this room i'm talking
about now she can't even say it with a
straight face no no i'm saying that
you're saying value me value me from my
experience but like they don't want that
they don't care you just said
that
your value is is dropping in the sexual
marketplace yes well sex isn't all that
you bring as a woman you bring more
things to them you bring more things
than just sex if it's just sex then
do you want to do you want to marry
someone you can't have sex with no do
you want to marry someone you can't have
something do you want to marry do you
want to marry me oh no
it starts it starts with sex is a big
part for women for women for women not
for men okay how big is sex to you and
in a relationship well it's
it will play
it will keep me in a relationship
no honestly like one question
may i like do you had best sex with uh
like 18 20 years old girl or with a 30
35 40 women
i i don't really tend to rate sex like
that when i go into sex no because we're
saying that we're dropping by age so
nobody's asking from your point of view
just do you know i'm not saying you know
what she's saying is about men as a
collective yeah this one what she's
saying is correct speaking to the macro
bro yeah and what she is saying is
correct because when women get to a
certain age men do see them as less
valuable yeah why i'm asking why because
she said youth purity you
you automatically see a younger girl she
looks younger she looks more attractive
you think that you hope that she's
has less mileage than an older woman
so naturally your first thought is i'm
dealing with someone who hasn't been run
through who doesn't have a higher
mileage her face moves there's no like
botox for hers right
so all of this now is it about going
into new relationships that's the point
i'm trying to get to yes is that what
you is that yeah so so the point is okay
if you're coming to a guy
over a certain age is it fair to expect
monogamy when you gave your best years
to someone else is that a fair deal is
that no i'm saying is that a fair deal
for men to be monogamous to you when
some other guy got your best years it's
unfair to assume that a woman's given
all her best years to someone else
because but you're telling men what to
value now i'm not telling men i'm saying
it's unfair to assume that a woman has
given her best to someone else okay so
that's like going up to guys and saying
they're saying hey you know i like 22
year olds maybe maybe 27 22 to 27 that's
that's what i think is the best and then
you're going up to guys and saying well
that that's not my best years i think my
best years are 30. when they're like um
when you say best what do you mean the
most valuable the most valuable but
valuable in what way and
the market wants it the most
okay so are you talking about bearing
children or bearing children the way you
the younger bearing children the way you
look um less bodies
everywhere
everything if someone is 40 and she's
had less bodies than a 20 year old and
she looks younger than the 20 year old
who's more valuable then
again because because you're looking
you're looking for an extreme excitement
show me show me one more time
show me one show me 140 show me one 40
year old that looks younger than a 20
year old i'm 35. i'm just younger
honestly speaking you don't want 20.
honestly i never said 20. yeah yeah
i'd give you 30. they're like 20 okay
that's from you one minute
i'm saying in general
i people don't believe me when i say my
age
so if a woman like myself who doesn't
look her age whose body count is lower
than a younger person who's been run
through as you're saying
would that mean that i'm less valuable
or more valuable than a younger girl who
looks older than me and has had more
bodies in in the marketplace you would
fall into an exception you would find
that men are extremely
surprised potentially to the point they
probably may not believe you but if
we're talking about a collective
most women will tell you that from 18 to
25 they got the most attention from men
and
after those years it dwindled and that
is the point she's making what she's
making is when you get to a certain age
you become less desirable
i can't believe
because you're not
exception and that's why it's blowing
your mind well but even at 30 but even
at 35 exceptions ninety ninety percent
of your eggs are gone by thirty so guys
no i'm like what i'm not i don't know
90 of your eggs are gone by 30. so if a
guy's looking for a wife he wants
someone that can give him kids so you're
less valuable because you are less
likely to give him kids and you are more
likely to lie about your body count so
you could say oh i have a low body count
but a guy's not going to believe you
he's like 35 you've been in the streets
for 15 years yeah okay
i don't see the sense in lying but i'm
speaking like i said i'm the exception
or whatever my eggs dwindling after 30.
i think that's really
awful to say that a woman's value is
less because her eggs i said in the
sexual marketplace okay well in the
sexual marketplace a woman's value is
less because their eggs whatever because
someone could be 18 or could be
diagnosed with an illness and they can't
have kids ever or there's probably women
that don't even want to have children
and they're living their best life okay
but when you're when you're arguing when
you're arguing the extremes that means
you are because you don't have a good
argument because that's not the rule and
you know i'm i'm just i'm just throwing
it out there i'm just saying it it's a
bit odd to
go ahead can i just say that
i don't know why women just don't get it
because is it women or me because just
say me
with you you're not the only i ever want
to say you would say you but i'm just
saying women as in general
because
it is because 35
right you can be looking good at 35 and
you can get with a man at 35 and say
you're gonna have
you're gonna get with this man you're
gonna have a five-year relationship with
him and then start having kids
think about your 35 you're gonna start
having kids at 40. it's not going to be
the same as somebody who is 20 being
with that man for five years and having
children it doesn't matter how good you
look it doesn't matter about your body
because you can't beat
biology
that's what's going to happen no but see
this again like what you're saying andy
is
is a is a great point it's like women
don't get it and
the facts are it's like
women can come out and say i want
someone who's
six foot plus two that drives a nice
german car that makes x amount of money
a year
and men have to accept that
men say
i want a woman who's got a low body
count
who doesn't go out
and
who looks good
and it will get challenged you can't hit
both ways
instead of listening to what we want
you have to challenge it and then you
get confused about why men straight so
like when she's saying men will go for a
younger woman
the stats are there that men are more
attracted to younger women
instead of looking at it and saying okay
well that's that's the just the truth of
the matter the same way short men accept
women like taller men
women need to accept that men have
certain standards
and that is what the facts are and the
thing is why is it that
when
when a woman tells a man this is what i
want the men gotta listen
but when the man is saying this is what
i want the woman like no no no no no no
no no no guys
i don't think we were saying that we
don't accept i just don't give up i
don't i don't care she's like
it's not like he is not the only man in
this
world like they think in this way cool
like he gonna find his 20 years old girl
okay give free child and whatever
like we are setting that we are setting
that we just think in a different way
which is a completely different thing
but of the car we are certainly cool
like
i like a six-foot guy and you are
setting it i'm fine with you getting
taking out a 20 years old girl
i'm looking good i can get any man i
want you know why because i might have a
low body count but i'm going to be what
all the men want you know what i mean
rubbish
and you can't get blood out of a stone i
don't care how good i look you can't
breed after a certain amount if you
gonna say oh yeah the upset she could
have a baby at 40. yeah you want to go
and be in the playground 65 million all
women want in school
but the women don't want children but
it's what they're doing one mic one
minute it's what the men want and the
most women are not listening to when
they're mental but men somehow have to
shut up and listen to where women are
talking about i'm not telling about what
you want when a man's telling you what i
want a man saying right now this is what
i want and the women like nah nah nah
nah nah you don't want it because i'm
all this
or
or no okay okay okay stop over talking
stop over talking me stop over no no
that's rude you're being very rude this
is my show
you're over talking me you're over
talking to me trying to stop me stop
stop wait wait till i'm done you can
wait till i'm done or the other way is
they say they don't care but if you're
selling a car
you have to study the people you're
selling to
and you don't go up to the people that
are buying and say oh you should want me
this is what you should want go ahead
the point i'm trying to make is you're
it's like you're assuming that you're
putting me in the box of people that are
saying oh no you can't want that because
i'm this way have me as i am i never
said that i said no i said
people should go for what they want if
you want a 20-something year old woman
go for that 20 sovereign woman that
wants a 40 30 year old man if there's a
30 year old woman or whatever who can't
have kids or doesn't want to have kids
or is too old to have kids or whatever
and she meets someone that is happy to
have her then that's like it shouldn't
be a combative thing where it's like
women don't listen and and men listen
and she should have to settle and should
have to listen to what women want blah
blah if there's a man that is four for
eight and he wants a tall woman and the
woman doesn't want him he has to accept
it if there's a woman that's 37 38 and
there's a guy who's earning a lot of
money ticks or boxes he doesn't want her
because she's old just to accept it
that's the point that i was trying to
make in the beginning was would you
blame a man for stepping out
if you had given
somebody else your best years and this
is why the men were saying what the best
years are but the women do not want to
hear from the men what the best years
are and when it comes to what the best
the best years for the men biology takes
a main part of it so it doesn't matter
how old you guys matter and
you guys were arguing about what the
best years were because you said gave
your best years to someone else that's
where i was a bit what do you mean gave
my best yeah it's not just the success
experience it's the it's that whole
especially when you've had a child for
someone else especially
i will say majority of men legacy is
very important do not yes there's a lot
of baby mamas around okay okay hold on
hold on and then this falls in with the
age thing as well because as we're
saying the older you're getting the more
barren you're becoming so then because
you're older you should accept that a
man will cheat on you is that is that
what we're saying we're a dialogue you
could die alone too so yeah but we don't
that's the point guys like not every
woman need a man like if that is want to
step out step out like when we are 30
that's my value when you say oh you're
not 20 anymore so you don't have any
value no i actually my value is that i
can stand by my own i can pay my bills
i'm independent and this is because i'm
party because when i was 20 i was
probably looking for a man to you know
help me out in you know just to in order
to
are you going to be happy 60 without a
family by yourself yeah because in in
the world i can do a lot of things i can
travel i can i can if i cannot have my
own baby i can adopt it i can have a pet
i can do whatever else i'm not just a
bloody baby machine honestly
i'm not a baby machine so my value it
doesn't depend from how many eggs i uh
still have children though
i don't know i still don't i never found
a man that let me think okay let's have
a baby still so if
i don't know i don't i don't wanna have
a child i don't think my life's gonna be
sad you're saying you want you want
children with the right man
you have to be the right man of course
i'm thirty now right so about what do
you wanna say is that
if you find the right man
right at 35.
you get in the relationship at 35
when are you gonna think about having a
child i don't know that can happen in
six months that can happen in two years
time that's not uh you know calendar and
we don't plan if i our life day by day
things just happens and i just don't
feel like i'm less vulnerable than 20
years old i'm just different so did you
know one out of three women under 30
have fertility issues one out of
everything
our food is different today so so i said
i leave a knife i want to tell you so
like so i i know but i'm saying for the
right guy so if you found the guy that
that you would have a kid with like that
that's more of a risk when you're older
yeah but he's free to go without 20
years old if he's just one think about
me as a baby machine it's free to go
with a 20 years old one girl i'm fine
i'm just functioning about my age i'm
happy
yeah we're talking about baby right now
so i just answered the question your
value
my value i'll explain to you i explained
to you just now that my value is not
about how many when men i slept with
it's not about how many eggs i contained
still because i'm not a baby machine my
value is about how many money i can make
because i probably can make more money
than a man out there
is about how what i can deal with life
every day i don't need a man this is my
value okay i stand by my own this is my
value so the question is can you find a
man that can stand next to me and deal
with me yeah but when you say that's
your value to him but who's that yeah
for me i don't i don't need to
like when you're selling something she's
talking about cars when you're selling
something it's you you decide the value
of your you don't think that
yes the market the market does so so
okay that's like me saying okay i'm nba
like an nba why an nba player would be
stuffy that's like that's like that's
like okay stop stop interrupting me
that's that's like me saying that i can
get a top one percent guy so i would say
i deserve a guy that can that can that
makes half a million but none are lying
lining up to buy me then i'm not i'm not
worth that that's your value and so so
you can't just tell men oh i'm still
just as valuable you need to tell
nothing but you just did you just went
off on the right side so
you just saw it i think
i'm gonna repeat clearly so i know very
clearly what i want okay now as i as you
said probably i'm not available so i
don't want to get what i want cool i
stay by my home i don't need a man like
oh i get what i want i guess i can just
say buy my own i don't need a man i
don't ever child
i'm like a person i'm not a baby machine
i'm not do you know what i mean like
that's my values
for what you're saying you don't sound
very happy about that no i just don't
i'm not very happy about how another
other women can think about our body and
our essence
i'm telling you what
that is approaching her whether he
chooses to go to her or on once or 20
whatever obviously he's approached her
so he likes her right so that's the
value that she brings that's that's the
point but i'm saying i've never talked
about you guys i don't know
the question is is that fair to expect
monogamy so i'm saying over a certain
age you're less valuable to men and then
as soon as i say as soon as i say that
you guys get triggered no no no and you
and you and you guys you keep you keep
interrupting me this is
stop this is rude this is my show it's
very rude to interrupt the host okay so
sorry like this is disrespectful sorry
carry on and so i'm saying that if
you're going to men and telling them
what they should value and every time i
say this is what men value you guys you
keep arguing with it then you want to
say well what are my best years this
this this and this i get that but i'm
just saying she asked the question and
said that this girl said she's 30 and
then you said you're 30. so when you get
to 30 you made it personal about her but
i don't know why no
sorry i don't know
his name but yeah she said once she gets
to 35 and then her eggs blah blah blah
she asked her something personal about
her so that's why it got personal
because you made it about honestly
that's why she was talking about herself
and not saying that you expect all men
to accept this value blah blah blah the
point is if if a certain man approaches
her and this is the value that she gives
or she brings and the guy doesn't want
it then that's fine
i can understand that you're saying that
this is men want xyz men want um
whatever you said from a certain age or
whatever as if to say no man approaches
a 30 or 35 year old woman when there's
two thirty-year-old women sat here who
men approach that's good well there's a
difference between like force that like
like it doesn't count unless you're
getting a brain none of it counts
it doesn't yeah it doesn't it doesn't
yeah
you can be approached your number can be
taken your instagram can be got but if
you're not being kept it doesn't matter
you can tell any man i get moved to 10
times a day
cool all right do you have a man no
maybe we don't i remember because we
don't want men like the majority of the
men okay so it's not about you taking
women is about we like each other we
find genetic match so you cannot talk
about as someone they've been taken but
again so
i learned something today yeah yeah
auntie
we me and auntie had a conversation rt
explained to me i said are you in a
relationship she said yeah i'm in a
relationship and i said does that so
does that mean you're not part of the 35
and over
leftover women which was a topic that we
were speaking about at the time and she
went
i'm still part of that category and i
said i don't get it like you're in a
relationship you've you've made it and
she went no
i have i've got i haven't got a ring
so i'm still a part of that category and
i didn't get it because i was like
why you're in a committed relationship
you're where you well actually
i'm in a committing relationship but i'm
a leftover oh i'm a leftover in a
committing relationship that was it and
that's what i actually said and even
when you was talking about the value
the difference with now is that yeah at
25 i was hot do you know me i was hot
slim hot you stink that's
nah yeah you are i just fooled myself no
no no no no no no i don't know what i
look hot for somebody of 53.
do you remember i'm fooling myself that
i look as hot as i am at 53 as i did at
25. no i'm just the obsession is that
the same man that i was with at 25 is
the same man that i was with now do you
i mean but other than that no
i don't see that and i'm not fooling
myself to say that you know i mean i was
lucky enough that he had my best years
and he still got my best years and i had
his best years but at the end of the day
i can't turn around and say i'm better
off for anybody else at 53 because
anybody else at 53 must have got a
wedding ring on they'd be married or
something like that but at the end of
the day if it weren't for a fluke i'm
just like everybody else yeah i'm a
leftover
in a committed relationship and that's
what women feel to realize that
yes before you think about
oh i'm going to be single i'm going to
be this and i'm gonna be that you gotta
fix yourself you know what
because before i started thinking like
that i was like you know i gotta get my
pension i gotta get my own house i gotta
get the house done in case i'm disabled
i gotta get my will gotta get my lpa
because
just in case you end up on your own
and you know something 32 years and i'm
still got that mindset you know what
because i'm still left over because i've
still got to think like that so i'm
going to think to myself yeah i've been
with the guy for like 30 something years
i got stuck i'll still think like that
you know what because i've got
i've got the same worth to him as i was
years ago or i look you know i mean oh
yeah you're a hot come on 53 right now i
think well the goal is marriage then is
that the goal should always be marriage
because that's when you know what guy is
committed to you and that's why i said
you can be a woman for today i was
talking the other week and i was saying
a man could be with you for 30 years 40
years 50 years whatever so there's a
ring and your finger is not committed to
you it can step out so you said you've
been with the same person that you've
been with since you were 25. no it's
before that yeah so since you were
before 25 and did you have kids or no we
got two separate children you've got two
so you've not had kids together now
since since you've no we haven't okay
that's interesting
and i can go around and say oh yes when
i was 35 i looked really good and we
could try and have children together
come on by the time you're 35 you picked
yourself yeah i could have better kid at
35 of him but then you gotta think to
yourself i know how old am i going to be
when i got the kid girl's nursery am i
going to be when the i'm going to go and
pick up my grandkids now i don't want to
be going picking up my child and they're
saying who's that is that your grandma
no it's my mommy and then nowadays
you're thinking about secondary school
or university i don't want to be you
know
70 years old and kind of picking up my
child and saying oh yeah they graduate
and you're playing with fire because um
the average if you want to freeze your
eggs and go that route like that it
costs like 25 000 there's no guarantee
it'll work the average person can afford
that
no i'm just thinking it's interesting
because you said you were together from
before you were 25 so what like 22 23
about that like 22 23 and then
but you you were in the like you guys
said the best years of your life
whatever and still didn't have still
having them
sorry you're still i'm still having that
no no i'm just going by what these are
i'm saying by the way by the worth from
the they said that i wouldn't have a
child from 35 onwards so according to a
man if a man wants to have a child and
that that would have been the time to
get to have a child then
not like 30 because by the time 30 comes
we like forget it and she don't make
forget it because i'm putting my body
through that by
according what um said your name again
kb kb
he said especially when a woman has a um
a child with uh before
that's the best year also because
there's a very strong and close
relationship between you know the your
your baby uh dad and
yourself right
so but you are actually just showing
that that's not true so yeah because
the difference is
you don't know my story the difference
is that i had an abusive relationship
that's why i've got no hangouts
completely different if it was a happy
relationship and i had my son and we
left
that'd be different
but i number one i was on contraception
when i had my son so he wasn't planned
and because of that reason that's why i
decided to have one child because i
would say one is a mistake
two you can say is an accident three is
careless four and above your what list
so as far as i'm concerned i had one out
of wedlock and that is it yeah but
anyway you had a child and your partner
evaluate you anyways as a valuable
viable woman so he actually spent after
the best here with you in this scenario
i wouldn't judge you
you know what i mean this is just
compromise he spent the best
that what are you guys saying it doesn't
happen
all right yeah
what they're trying to say is that if
i'd met him at 30
why should he be faithful to me when
i've given my best years to some other
man if i stayed with my baby father yeah
until i was 30 and then said you know
what i'm gonna get back with
the first one the one i'm with now
why should he be monogamous why should
he stay with me because you have low
enough stuff no because i've already
given up my good life my good the best
of my life when i was young free
sexy agile fling my legs over my
shoulders was all between the ages of
20.
she knows because because of the nurse
no i don't know because
it's you're it's not valuable to me
you don't you don't you don't have the
youth and you don't have the purity at
30. it's gone so it's you don't have
what men value okay as i said
first of all right now uh 20 years old a
girl cannot have purity anymore because
they probably lose their virginity when
they 12. but let's forget about it so if
that the point that means that every
woman that uh as child a child before or
yes relationship important relationship
before could not have a husband later
and i saw a lot of people that actually
had child
before and after they get married or
whatever so what do you mean that uh the
man they actually you know
wifey air is a
i don't know it's a bum like
a bum well men don't i don't care about
your job
like you could like you could do nothing
and like men do not give a [ __ ] like
because you said earlier like i make
money and i'm like well not to men
that's like a shoe collection to women
like a guy if a guy says if a guy says
oh i have a cool shoe collection we're
like oh that's cool but then we keep
moving that's that's how men feel about
work
okay so they like
they'd prefer a girl that like does
nothing so she can like hang out with
them and like don't on them
good yeah i mean
one one person can get married
unemployed not two
yeah unless you know that she looks like
michael b jordan
honestly speaking um me myself because
we're talking about what are men
expecting from our women but we're not
talking about what are women expecting
is expecting from our men and then
because we always hear it
because we always
no no did you did you in my point of
like you think like what are we talking
about now is just a part of the you know
men in the world which is probably the
majority but doesn't mean that is the
totality guys
so
okay anyway it's fine yeah we can we can
keep saying that's the majority and i'm
i'm i'm fine with that cool all right
but again we said that but we want that
majority a man going out and saying okay
cool i want to go and find a virgin yeah
and we're gonna go and find this virgin
it's the same way you're saying
oh i'm gonna be this exception and i
will find that guy who wants me no but
you're saying
no no no no no you didn't get my point i
don't give a [ __ ] to find the men who
evaluate me because i know i know about
my value i don't need a man to recognize
my value i don't give a [ __ ] if i gonna
find them cool
but you if i don't i can stand on my own
i'm paying my bills
i got a job what i do what do i need a
man for okay do you have sex but that's
fine i can still have sex
i have a question i have a question for
you how do you determine what your value
is right i told you i told you a woman
for me is an independent woman who can
stand by his own can pay air bills he
has the maturity to understand even when
is the right time to have a children
because everyone can have a child any
time just you know and then those people
it's also about how we have our you know
what kind of parent we are so it's not
just about having eggs because honestly
i prefer women that stay without
children instead that someone that who
doesn't deal with properly so question
who is that valuable to
what you just listed who is that
valuable to you mean who who yeah who is
that valuable to
what you just myself i don't care about
other people's opinion okay so i i need
to like that's just to people that i
should like
worry about god and myself
not about
okay so
so i just want to clarify so you don't
care what men want
and and the way you determine your value
is what you say yeah isn't that a bit
narcissistic no he's not
because
you only care about yourself and not
what anyone else wants no listen to the
point i don't i didn't say it just about
myself just about the people that
actually is in in my small circle
which is different because when someone
comes inside my circles they actually
understand my value i don't need to
explain to them
so that's the point the other point
obviously i don't i don't give a [ __ ]
about any uh no offense but really about
people that is not in my small circle so
like okay i'm not vulnerable okay cool
like peace like i'm gonna come back to
my life i'm gonna go to work tomorrow
i'm gonna keep paying my bills and you
know what i mean like okay
so you you basically turn into that like
this is what girls do though like women
turn into the men they want to marry so
if you're looking for a guy like all the
things i'm not looking for a guy no no
no i know you're not i'm saying but like
typically i'm saying in general i don't
know you personally but i'm saying in
general when women become the men they
want to marry so they become all the
things that like men want because what
she just described that's the mat like
that's the man i would date but it's not
women it's not what men want yeah like a
guy that's independent that pays his
bills that goes like he gets the back
i'm like sign me up but to a man that's
like
that's a red flag
men don't care what a woman about her
career yeah that's what i said so then
if she's making money getting her bag
whatever whatever a man wouldn't care no
no no no
so then her value so then a man will
approach her then a man will want her a
man because you walk into tesco and see
an attractive girl at the till i agree
he wants to change her life um a woman
will not walk into tesco see an
attractive man that's what you think i i
i guess you agree
honestly that's fine that's not the
totality it's not the totality i had
i've been in relationship with men there
honestly
less than me they had absolutely nothing
and where are they now
what does it mean that i like what about
other other men that are six foot and
they i don't know the billionaire they
anyway
go like you know if you if you meet a
billionaire you're dating a billionaire
you fumble the bag
i actually i actually like com comparing
i had probably had more relationship
with people that you know are
less rich than someone that i probably
didn't give a chance i didn't give a
chance to them right so it's not
absolutely you've dated like broke guys
is what you're saying i had some not
broken like
do you think you attract feminine guys
because you're more masculine uh
no i wouldn't say feminine
honestly just people with balls which is
different it's not about being
yeah it's not about being feminist it's
about be very confident because when
you're standing next to me because i
think i'm tough i got strong personality
you need both honestly
someone else who prefer a young lady who
doesn't work who can be manipulated and
can be general control because you are
strong in the relationship i need a man
it doesn't really is a partnership like
we are together we strong in the same
way when a man is looking for a younger
lady which is virgin who doesn't work he
probably aren't less than me it's
because they need to feel like they are
the strongest one they are controlling
they controlling
they taking the power in the
relationship
you're just deciding what you believe
men no that's my point of view yeah your
decision
i'm not deciding i'm expressing my point
of view of you no you're deciding you
said i'm not deciding you are you said
men go for younger women because they
feel they're going to control them and
manipulate them what if what if men said
that about women they would look so
stupid if they're like like women like
rich guys because they want to
manipulate and control them people be
like that's a cope you just need to go
make money and it's the same thing when
women say things like that to men like
you're shaming them
shame guilt like this is like the common
tactics are shame guilt insult wait
shame guilt
shame insult guilt and need to be right
yeah no i'm not need to that's the point
guys you have like you work like you're
working like a horse you don't see like
on the left and right yes because i
accept in your point of view by you
saying that i want to control your own
mentality
no wait wait wait wait wait wait and are
you telling the room how the
you're telling the room how they
experienced you no you're not you're
you're telling me if more than one
person if more than one person in the
room no you guys are saying like how a
man should look
no i never said your name yeah i don't i
don't know what you do
honestly when i say to me i'm saying to
women because i belong to the actually i
don't know if you guys realize but yeah
i'm a girl so the category of women
women now me myself
you belong to women yes and we're
talking about what men want from women
you then take yourself out of belonging
to women to say what you are
no you you've been doing that no i just
i'm standing you just said yeah i belong
to women right and the discussions we're
having is what men want from women
you represent the totality of men in
this world
do you represent the totality of man in
this church
guilt need to be right
no the statistics need to be right i
don't need to be right like statistics
which statistic because like it's based
on what like honestly
statistics day the majority of there are
i could i could i could
let's say let's take the static the
statistic you're right and you come up
with the best number ever okay let's
let's say that okay cool so the majority
of men think like you right all right
cool i'm accepting that you prefer at 20
years old women i just don't give a [ __ ]
is it clear like i don't give a [ __ ] so
you can prefer go out with a 20 years
old girl have child married uh whatever
you wish i hope you do
i hope you do kids
go get that 20 year old you know i'm a
certainly right cool i just don't give a
[ __ ] that's fine as you don't give a
[ __ ] about what i think so why you
cannot just say okay this is just a
different point of view as am i setting
your point of view
that's cool that's cool for me like
you're you're quite you're quite angry
for being great no i'm not i'm not love
trying to communicate my point which is
different i'm not angry to you like to
anyone else just my point i want to make
it clear because i think i've been
invited for this reason
that's the point i'm not angry at all
like honestly speaking okay all right
cool good good it's passionate yeah
there we go i'm just italian guys
give me food and conversation i can
i love that okay
are men or women the prize
you ask in the room yeah yeah our men
are women the prizes go around
all right cool give me a sec oh women
are so women the prizes women are
depressed okay
wait tell me why
because they're the ones that we're
going for well me personally i'm getting
for the woman
and i want to go for the women that i
believe is the right woman and someone
who else
many people would want okay go ahead
no i meant at the price um
we we run to site we keep society going
i'm not saying women
i knew she's gonna go men of the prize
will win another prize okay what do you
think men or women who's surprised
the
the prize for like i'd okay wait let me
just
so
are men or women the prize in what sense
like in the world or in in the dating
game in the dating game
well women okay women are the prize what
do you think
that's 50 50 50. you think like half of
women half a man okay fair enough go
ahead
men men are the price what do you think
auntie
i think men there's more women anyway so
i can remember the prizes so many of
them running out around there it's gotta
be men so second question are do women
date up or down
they day up okay
when they can help here okay do women
date up or down
are they up yeah i answered for me
personally up oh
i'm not losing okay
they date down they sleep up
up
yo that's cold
that's cool
so if women if women date up wouldn't
that make men the prize
that's a good point it makes sense
really
yeah
yeah
i get the point but i i don't i still
don't see men as the price
why not look
so let me get this right you've
acknowledged the point
honestly i understand
i understand the point allow me to
finish so you've acknowledged the point
right but you don't agree
can you explain why
no i you asked me who are the prize and
relate i could still i'm still i'm in an
iron about the question about the aunt
the question
anyway like who's the prize sort of
because then it's like the whole value
thing and all that sort of stuff so
that's why i just said women just to
give an answer that women are the prize
because of
what they bring to a relationship or
whatever it is right i just said it just
whatever but then what was it you said
again that
why do women they are i said i said do
women date up or down i mean so if
majority of the the women here said they
up yeah why would and a man would be the
prize yes but then dating up
you're not dating down so
so if if they're dating up then the men
are dating down
because
oh no but yeah but if women are dating
up
and men are dating down you're saying
that women are not the prize that a man
is the prize yeah so then men would just
date men because men are the prize why
are men dating down if a man is
surprised when all men just date all men
no they
okay we're talking we're talking about
straight people okay yeah they wouldn't
they wouldn't date why would men date
each other when they're straight i like
this isn't it you just said men are the
people would make men the price yeah
because men could date up but they don't
they date down yeah so then men would be
the prize that means they don't have a
choice there's some there's some women
there's some women that would be up
there are some women that would be down
there are women that would be up like
oprah is up right so then a man has to
be above her
to date down to her why are you saying
that oprah's not um no i'm just general
like i'm just saying like value money
whatever i can't think of a young rich
no no no that's not up though so what's
up then got points
or a woman that is that margot robbie
so someone that's young someone who's
just yeah exactly
actually i think she hit 30. i gotta
find someone that's 22. but
so
young and pretty basically yeah
with a lot of eggs yeah so if she's
young and pretty and works in tesco yes
exactly yes
it depends on her personality as well
okay a personality that she works in
tesco personality she's 20 she's young
she's her body count is zero whatever
then you're then then the man is dating
up yeah yeah do you know her there's
some guys that might want her
that's the point so she would be
considered high
so she's high value yeah yeah yeah
in the dating market yeah so then
wait
here here's my thing yeah you're now
starting to understand how men think we
we're totally
yeah the [ __ ] is right so
if that is a woman that is high value
yeah
and then
why would that woman want to date you
wouldn't she want to date someone high
value someone up yeah yeah yeah
yeah
yeah right so then
wait i don't know
you know what i see where you're going
with this because you're saying high
value women go for high value men yes
you're saying they're correct that
there's an equality there yeah
the low value man who is trying to date
up she doesn't want you right now
correct
yes that's why that's why one in three
men are virgins or haven't had sex in
the past year because nobody wants them
so so you're saying men are dating down
yeah so by dating down you're saying
he's dating someone
over 25 30 whose body count is up whose
eggs are cracked and yeah i mean guys
guys he's dating down guys will put up
with more than men do so they will put
up with more and date i'm sorry yeah the
the guy will put up with more and date
down yeah because he doesn't have a
choice but he'll still cheat on that
woman he still has a right to not be
monogamous to her
because her value is low it depends but
you don't have a choice because no the
high value woman doesn't want you so
you're dating down right but a lot of
high-value women die alone because
that's not what
i mean
wait wait wait what are we defining as a
hive sorry sorry i'll explain a lot of
it is
i'll explain a lot of eight to tens that
are very pretty die alone because they
can't leave the streets because they're
so used to the attention
like that
like
what sorry go ahead guys what do you
mean by that
um this is like honestly i've just heard
this from guys this is like strictly
this is just the experience that i've
had like talking to guys the last like
two years yeah and they just say a lot
of girls that are like very pretty and
they're given like that's the most
valuable thing you can be given is
extreme beauty like you come out you can
get a modeling contract and girls waste
it and they waste their best years that
doesn't make you high value just because
you're right you're right sorry sorry hi
technically if we're gonna go high value
woman the man i misused the term like a
high value woman technically has to be
chosen by a high-value man i just met
like like very attractive women that are
like the most sought after they wouldn't
be you're right i use those terms
yes and i'm saying like
a lot of like the most beautiful women
die alone because they're they're so
used to being like an eight to ten yeah
that's their whole personality they
can't they don't break up they've never
been bullied like like if you tell a
girl she's not special they freak out
which is weird most people aren't
supposed to tell you well go ahead that
would make you low value
if you're if you're beautiful but you
don't have any other qualities you're
still in the streets you're still a
whole you're low value yeah yeah
equivalent would be a [ __ ] i don't
know a cryptocurrency well you're not
you're not low value if you're a dating
game
if you're if you're beautiful
you like like someone that's 300 pounds
isn't going to get in the same like she
could have a no body count you're going
to get the initial attention yeah but if
you have nothing else and you're a whole
yeah
like your background
correct correctly
but that's that's why i say like girls
that are eight to tens often die alone
that's that's what i was saying because
because they're so used to that
attention that they it's like a drug
they can't they can't they can't so wait
wait this is just this is just what i've
heard from men okay so like not sure but
it depends on no but honestly it depends
on your culture your background
like sorry generally speaking
if you look at
we can go to like instagram chicks yeah
the majority of them are single your
bernie's
order them and they may get gifts they
may get dated but
are they kept
how many of them do you see that are
kept
this is the point that you're referring
to looks only but that's what that's
what we're saying eight to tens yeah but
that's that's low value so no no no so
what you're saying is that that's with
life when you start with looks like we
as much as people want to pretend that
you know this personality stuff matters
the initial attraction is looks yeah so
when you are
attractive and you have pretty privilege
yeah you're gonna get attention so what
she's saying is when you get that sort
of attention it's like a drug
you go out and you know that you're
gonna have the pick of men
coming to attract and move to and talk
to you and sell you dreams exactly right
but you're still not being kept at the
end of the day no one is going to turn
that attraction and those dreams into
marriage into a ring and they die alone
right i understand that but you could
you could say the same
for some men
but
like a dude can be 50 and a girl that's
30 will still find him fine but like
it's it's not the same vice versa you
could be 50 and a [ __ ]
and you're not attractive as a guy yeah
you could be a guy
you have all the money in the world but
you're just not well mostly you don't
turn women on correct most men have died
a lot like yeah i think for only 40 only
only 40 only 40 percent of men have
reproduced throughout history
so where 80 of women have so the
majority of men do die alone you're
right
it's just a new thing for women
because like they they get because they
don't listen to what men want anymore
so how do we fix that that's coming from
what happened how do we how do we like
level the playing field there you're
doing it slowly well i mean to me it's
like the it's the
you you get rid of the consequence more
people do it so if you pay women to
leave marriages the more girls are going
to do it they're paid through child
support and through the government
like when you pay women to make bad
decisions every bad decision we make
we're bailed out of you could be
homeless there's a women's shelter to
take care of you
you could sleep around you can get an
abortion to bill you out like whatever
bad decision women make there's a
bailout there's incentives yeah like
like so if you're paid to make bad
decisions more women make bad decisions
like they're not going to stop they're
not going to stop till the consequence
goes away
yeah yeah that was a big thing in this
country
what did you say earlier there's she
didn't know she didn't hear it and i
said in my day mm-hmm you know women
were just kind of they're getting
pregnant together
yeah yeah yeah yeah it's the first time
i heard of it and i said yeah i said but
there was a stigma then mm-hmm you know
what about it
reality hard because if a man makes a
bad decision or if he ain't [ __ ] the
world will tell him yeah well they will
feed women lies and let her live in
delusion
like even even when i said you're less
valuable when you hit 30. like that
shouldn't be that's just life yeah i'm
less valuable than i was when i was 22
which is what it is it's not it's not a
personal attacker
we're not talking about personal worth
but
honestly honestly honestly to everyone
like your looks are currency girls don't
even like we don't know how good they
have it
because you are given more attention and
opportunity because of the way you look
life is on easy mode as a young pretty
girl
[ __ ] like hit hit 50. let life change
everything
that's right but you you're like
auntie thank
we see it every day in the world but
people still choose to argue the fact
it is true as a 21 year old your life
was different to how it is now it is a
fact
it is a fact when you were younger you
were more attractive
you went out you you felt fresher no
it's not about being to me honestly no
honestly i'm gonna i'm gonna ask you
something then um it happened to me to
have many friends they actually prefab
like date older they're trying to get
there they're trying to [ __ ] you yeah
like
that
men are trying to [ __ ] you a 20 years
old girl as a 15 years old women that's
not different they are thinking just to
i don't want to be rude but like you
know what i mean they are thinking about
that from the principle
so
if uh
old women get you know less attractive
whatever it is
so anyway that's quite good looking 15
years old women that they actually
dating 20 or 30
years old man
do you even got money it's not even
not money no no it's not it's not it's
not even like honestly me personally i
had friends
very good look six foot guys very good
looking guys
they actually
dated
older women did they marry also child
did they marry them well what intended
what did they
it doesn't count unless he commits to
you for life so yeah
he's 26 years old give him the time to
get married i could i could i could say
okay i dated a guy that was a
millionaire does that mean make me a
millionaire wife no no no no yeah but
that's not actually if you don't result
the results so first of all that's not
the result for myself because i uh 20
years old women who can get married when
she's 22 so she's so
valuable or whatever she got a lot of
eggs she can be left alone when she is
25 and the husband is sleeping around
around and gonna left her alone looking
after the child so what about the value
we're talking about she's still 25 she
gives you our best life her best she's
valuable and she is she is by herself
now so what about this
what about this let's go ahead and say
why don't you get married before she had
the kid no no i said
you getting uh 20 years old women with a
lot of eggs you know beautiful and and
everything so very you know up upstairs
no childless okay so you get married
with her yeah you get you got a pregnant
so let's say you got one child or
whatever
now
how many cases we know about men leaving
the house with the child children or men
still cheating on them
cheating
guys if she was that available so why it
went outside to looking for actually
because because cheating is different
for men and for women no that men can
have sex with a whole lot and what about
when they leave the cheese men don't
worry about
women leave 70 to 80 of the time 90 if
you have a college degree 90 percent of
the time you're leaving
men
men by and large are not leaving so
that's not who do you men and women
cheat at equal rates i'm not talking
about
lot of children left alone from their
dad
okay i know a lot of single mothers and
they've been left alone okay you can you
can know it but you can look at who
files a divorce the difference that's
the that's they probably never even get
married but that's not good
but the difference from what she's
saying
is that the big difference is what you
said that he married her yeah that gives
her status who cares if he's sleeping
out she's covered everything goes
married that's what i was going to say
an ex-wife and a baby mama are two
different things
guys
the man has sorry auntie jenny just give
me one second guys i'm gonna reiterate
the rules because we're not getting
there
one at a time people at home can't hear
you it's a great conversation i want you
guys to have this conversation but i
need to be able to hear you so please
allow each other to speak one at a time
thank you
let's get into it
you got
a young girl you say 25 with a kid
and the man marries her lisa goes and
sleeps out
you got that's his 25 yeah yeah you got
25 year old woman
not married the man has a kid with van
lisa
who's at the better advantage the one
that got married
what's your point of view
because they making everything about
status and what society think about
women no we're making a reason no we're
making sure
so she gonna be results about being
married
that's like me saying i'm an olympian
with no metal
like like women live like this is what i
mean like you like that's delusion like
women women go through life living in
delusions but everyone has different
pain like
focus in life
if i if i have a ring then i am
protected i if i i okay okay your mic is
off because you keep interrupting me if
i have a ring that i'm entitled like
then i am protected legally i'm
protected legally if you're from wall
from
you can turn it on go ahead oh i was on
mute this whole time okay but if if he
if he's cheated on you like a 20 year
old he's married her she's young she's
got eggs whatever whatever he's married
her they've had vows they've had a child
and he's cheated she's okay because
she's got a ring she's basically broken
up
so you said that there was the 20 year
old who got married had a baby and he
cheated and then you got the 25 year old
who had a baby but didn't get married
and he cheated or let's just say they're
both the same age right right the one
that had a ring is more special because
she got a ring she's more protected
okay she's protected by law because it's
husband wants okay
yeah exactly so like let's say so so
because sorry i hadn't finished so
because she's protected by the ring that
makes her more valuable because she got
the medal let's be real she's got
results
and didn't let me finish okay go on so
then sorry i've just you just said the
result was the ring but the result was
that he she got cheated
okay allowed to finish a lot all right
cool
all right no it's just like they're both
they're they're both at a loss it's not
one is better than the other they're
both equal okay well it's not no no it's
not equal because once we're married
this is my point so one's protected so
because she got married she's protected
by law because of the yes
can we be real about life
i'm just taking it i'm not disagreeing
i'm not saying it to make it clear so if
we're being clear about life
like you said we have two women in
identical positions but one is married
and one is not
if you're not married and it all goes
pear-shaped you're gone you're out
there's nothing you can't go nowhere and
say well he cheated on me i should get
half sorry love you're not married
forget about it if you're married you're
entitled yeah yeah in life let's be real
you're getting half okay cool i've been
cheated on emotionally you might be sad
for a bit um but again as they say do
you want to cry
in a bentley or in the fiat
and go and stay go back home to your mom
or stay in a room with your friend
or do you want to get the house
and men look at and men look at ex-wives
and ex-girlfriends different okay so men
look at ex-wives and ex-girlfriends
different because because one has
results and they can say oh that man
chose her she was worth being chosen
where a girl that's that's over a
certain age they're like why nobody
choose you because i know other guys
aren't stupid so why didn't anyone
choose you why aren't you so then the
two women that were both 20 years old
that got cheated on at 25 or whatever
and then one was married one wasn't if
now they're both 30 and in that 10 years
they were so heartbroken couldn't admit
date anyone else they're now 30 with a
child one was married one wasn't you
would go for the pudding they're left
over then put in left over so no so you
wouldn't go for either of them like why
are you getting divorced for when you
got married why are you getting divorced
because
i've just said he tried
nothing women no you're not listening to
what i just said i said they would think
situations no i said both were 20 one
was married one wasn't they both had a
child each one they both were cheated on
and then after 10 5 10 years or whatever
now they're ready to date again because
they couldn't date when they had a young
baby or whatever now the child is five
six seven eight years old too young
today and they're sorry that's too young
what's too young have you got a child
five years old
and you've been mad you guys are adding
extra stuff like just i'm trying
now that the the two women that one was
20 both were 20 one was married one
wasn't whatever they've now come to 26
27 8 whatever years old you're saying
that the one that was married that
divorced she's more valuable than the
one that wasn't i'm just trying to man
yeah yeah so then you would date the one
that so you would still go for that one
with a child who was divorced
yep more like okay
and and the number can we stop acting
like like men are out here cheating all
the time the majority
but i'm saying i'm saying
i'm saying i'm saying i'm saying the
majority of men aren't even having sex
wait guys wait and the wait wait and the
number one reason for divorce is
financial reasons okay so i'm just going
off the conversation that was happening
before you gave a scenario of two women
one both twenty one one divorced one did
it who gave i didn't give that to you
yeah exactly guys but i was trying to
make another point like if the man got
the most valuable women ever because she
was young pretty whatever
why they still
live
those women if they are
we don't do they do because i know quite
a lot of single mother
so they've been left alone so single for
those single mothers
being left alone being left alone did
the man leave or did they choose the men
the men
the men
married
i like honestly speaking like i have
very close i had very close
very close relationship
and then after he left for
honestly speaking so
like what we talking about man anyway
can get even the best women ever the
most vulnerable that we're talking about
whatever in our she can give him her
best
but
i'd say that's insignificant by and
large it's not true the women are
leaving it's not men
okay
honestly i came next time i'm gonna come
with number two so probably i'm gonna
prove that the stories that you have are
probably the exception
that's quite a lot there's quite a lot
of single part and single mapping single
quite a lot yeah quite low it's probably
like 15 15 or more
yeah and that's a
my new amount to the whole thing and so
what
they're saying is i see more divorced
divorced couples than moderate buyers so
in your in your circle would you say men
left more than women yeah definitely
from people that you know yeah men have
left more than women yeah
yep and the thing is that a lot of what
women don't fail to realize is
how hard it is for a man to get married
in the first place men don't take that
lightly
men don't take it lightly and i don't
think they realize the importance that
every man decides to put a ring on your
finger he can have 15 women out there he
decided to put a ring on your finger
that means something because marriage
does not come easy to make it every man
decides that's who i'm going to marry
that puts you up there whether you think
whether he's got 15 women or not
but that person because
men are risking losing everything like
men
men are risky
men no men are risking ruin their
ruining their entire life if they marry
you because they say because you can
leave take half their [ __ ] and take the
kids with you and then they have to pay
you to take their kids yeah because they
don't even mind probably about their
children
is that is that what you think of men
some of them yes
because if you want to build a real
relationship you
gonna
very
you're going to look for someone that
actually can deal with everything and
when i'm saying everything i don't mean
cheating because loyalty is actually on
the basement of every relationship so if
you want you know men have lost their
entire life savings trying to get
custody of their kids from mother's day
i know because like me personally
i know about i had two brothers and
they've been they coming from uh first
my my dad first married so i know quite
well so i'm talking about something that
actually be involved during my life so i
know what i'm talking about but i'm
saying that's that's such a high risk
for a guy
so if a guy is putting a rail willing to
put a ring on your finger that means
something like you just took actually
the right uh example because like my dad
had two children from a woman who was
the virgin we talking about
she was 18 years old when she met my dad
and they had two two children
and the marriage and up all right and my
dad actually fight to you know see the
children all right
so
you see even though she was the
most like i mean obviously considering
your standard so your standard guys
she was a very valuable girl but anyway
the marriage end up and who win i will
say no one definitely my brothers they
suffer quite a lot
but
she didn't win because she had the ring
because after my dad's married another
my mother yeah and then then she kept
thinking actually
actually yeah that's that's horrible
yeah this is horrible win so she won
because she had the ring who won in this
story where did she win it just means
she won more than the girl who never got
the ring it doesn't mean she won in life
the one who wins is the one now
the one who wins is the one who gets
married and stays married
no i i think she had a very very sad
life because
you know when you get that angry to take
your children from your ex-husband you
having a very hard time you having a
very sad life even though you got the
ring you got [ __ ] and you got [ __ ] okay
i'm gonna i'm gonna i'm gonna
get married so um i do you wanna get
married but i'm gonna read the super
chats real quick so i'm gonna take a
second to do that and then you can ask
that question you can be the first one
to ask a question if you guys have to go
to the bathroom feel free to go now
also they're probably going to be mean
i'm just warning you okay um supper
saying sketch lady in the middle doesn't
know what the best number one woman in
her eyes not is not in men's eyes ask
the men in the middle how many friends
she has mgtow by logic italia you think
that all men cheat because you only
sleep with men in the top 20 percent of
men yeah we in the top 20 percent of men
don't know what we want
do no do what we want not what you want
but that doesn't mean the other 80
percent of men behave as badly as you do
you're delusional um drazy and gaming
god please come back to me when you talk
to please don't come back talking to you
middle one
actually okay guys i'm gonna do over
over 10 super chats just because there's
so many i don't think i can get through
them
maybe over ten dollars okay alter void
stop the lies you know single women that
lie about being left the truth they they
just know now they've [ __ ] up and they
need to be the victim and you're lying
to and your friends are lying to you
um
vudoki to be fair i don't know any
married men that cheat on a wife that
makes his sexual needs a priority if
that's accurate and accurate
generalization than when a man cheats
who who really broke the valve first oh
that's a good point um vuduki to
my ideal woman attractive fit
affectionate part-time job at most
homemaker while i work 70 hours a week
making good money is that chauvinistic
sounds like pretty laid back life for a
woman to me
let's go to the next ten dollar one okay
matt butcher women need to hear some
anti-jenny wisdom at 14. it would solve
extant this existential world problems
silly sausage they don't get it did
anyone actually ask her to start stating
everything that has about that they
don't get it did anyone actually ask her
to start stating everything that is
valuable about herself no one asks you
to put up your personal trauma walls
don't move the goal post with emotion
like cake for mr ever the woman in the
middle is going to die alone with no
family all men don't care about how much
money you make have fun with that and
ask yourself when you're all alone
having your fun matt butcher this is
great we get to see the effects of
feminism on full display real time what
to watch out for mgtow by logic can a
man stand by you no man wants to stand
by you that's the point of everyone is
telling you wake up your value to a man
is plummeting hourly listen to auntie or
die alone um bane split cheers cheers
pearl keep it in line ten dollars from
the blackest panther are we surprised
that 30 year old women are disagreeable
and annoying men do not care about your
experience the more experience a woman
has the more baggage she has and the
lower her value is to other men mgtow by
lodge at 50 super chat
the buyer determines the value always
men are the buyer just like you
determine what you value in men you
don't date bums do you know stop shaming
men you are 30 and alone you better
listen to anthony you've already wasted
12 years
um tg love love love auntie also pearl
if you want to experience the ultimate
red pill look up yuri ben's something
and um our call's going to be allowed
i'll be down from the chicago area
black is panther it's not hard to tell a
woman with a high body count combination
of these frequently wants to go on girls
trips bars and clubs or has high alcohol
areas constantly on social media for
attention
um
the next is ten dollar mr mt lavadair
hello from colorado usa i live in the
mountain ski town all the girls here are
ran through please help i i literally
can't help you um
um condor mayanda you all be really
putting in the red pill red pill work
for eight hours straight and then i'm
gonna refresh it real quick
um
okay so you you said you had a question
you wanted to ask yeah but they've left
they left
oh actually there's one there's one more
super chat um cv boy god my girl really
hated that i started watching you yeah
don't don't tell your girlfriends
um go ahead now my question was
um like who actually wants to get
married and why
um yeah that was my main question
two minutes um i i wanted to the guy oh
to the guys okay very good
he wants to get married and where yeah
and what in what regard like what were
you referring to i was asking the men do
you want to get married if that says yes
then why if it's no then why
i personally still believe that marriage
is quite beautiful um i know it's a risk
because like as we've called with the
statistics most women end up leaving
but i still think it probably plays back
to my my upbringing i just feel like
marriage is just a natural next step
um in in the progression of a
relationship so you do you want to get i
would love to get my idea so
but i also think to add on to that to
that marriage is more beneficial for
society
because even throughout history if you
look at that polygamous societies one of
the things that they see that's
prevalent is there's a lot of like great
there's a lot of crime because
in polygamous societies the strongest
men take all the women which leaves the
other men to revolt and cause problems
so monogamy's actually beneficial to
society keeps women safe it makes
society by enlarged more better nuclear
family homes lead to less
traumatic experiences for children so
you can see there's a lot of benefits
through marriage so yeah there's
all right but you actually didn't really
answer the question like why you want to
get my you why you want to again it's a
beautiful thing
okay you already said that beautiful yes
it puts your key in every single
advantage over that being in a situation
where you're not married yes so why like
what so it's more beneficial for kids
don't have children now right no it will
be beneficial uh it will be yeah yeah
yeah so now the point i was trying to
get is
if like if you have a reason for why you
want to get married
and you believe in
marriage and the vows that you've made
whether it's to god or wherever then why
would you then
go against those vows and cheat and then
it's for some reason it's okay first of
all i haven't cheated no no i'm just
because the guys have left and they were
here before i'm gonna ask them no i hear
what you're saying but
i hear what you're trying to do i hear
what you're trying to say but you have
to remember and we've mentioned this
before that
although marriage is what sought after
and it's more beneficial for our
offspring one the reason i seek marriage
is because
it's better for my kids to be raised in
a nuclear family
but even though it's still it's
marriage is still not my biological
imperative
i have to sacrifice elements of my
biological being
to conform to the female standard if i
had my way i'd have my woman that i love
and there's women i just chopped him out
again if i had my way but to conform to
the social standards of society
i try to be in a monogamous situation i
don't aspire to be a man that cheats
however anything that hasn't happened
it's just a prediction of the future
what i'm saying and i think most men
will put it that way so i'm just saying
this look if you've got a good man
and he steps out once in like once or
twice in 40 years
listen the grass isn't green until you
water it the grass isn't green on the
other side so i think that's the thing
that women have to recognize does that
work both ways of course not
because men can love multiple women at
the same time where women can only love
moon man and if she's cheated if she's
cheating on you you don't love him no
but you you use an example yeah could
you just walk out now
see a guy attracted to you and say
listen go [ __ ] me in the corner right
now could you do that so that's could
you could you do that from me personally
i couldn't most women most women
couldn't i didn't
yeah so most people don't want to behave
like that you see a man if he sees a
girl he's attracted to you i will bang
you in the bush
i'll bang in the street corner i'll bang
in the yard it don't matter it is what
it is but that's the that's the
fundamental difference so so why it
can't be flipped around is because it
takes more for you to allow someone in
whereas for a man it's like taking a
piss so that's why it's different but
why is it accepted no i don't think you
get one trying to say why is he accepted
no because if if a woman cheats yeah
there's a reason behind why she's
cheating of course so then why is it
that if she cheats you can't just accept
it it's because it goes beyond sex
there's the emotions involved that for a
woman to let a guy in there's a process
it's it's premeditated it's never just a
slip up for a man it's literally like i
wasn't using my head and i had a nut to
bust and that's that's all it is but for
you it goes further than that okay but
what if it was a slip up if it was a
girl
she just had a one-night stand
that's not a slip-up am i bending you
over and blasting your back yeah she's
on holiday that's premeditated you've
got that holiday i want wanting to [ __ ]
her brother
if you love a man if you love a man
you're not looking if you really love a
man you're not you're not looking at
anyone else you only see him listen to
what i'm saying i said if you are in a
situation where you're married and your
woman slipped up and just one time she
slept with someone just on holiday you
know what do you know what you take her
i see you're doing here and
you're you're trying to use the
exception to that it's not to me no
there is because most women wouldn't
behave that most women aren't slipping
up later giving a scenario in that
scenario i'd like to think but it can
never happen i will just fall and die if
i hear that
my immune system will shut down i'll
just get covered and i'll pass away okay
so would you take her back i could not i
couldn't because you know what by look
by by by holistically that's not how
women behave so how am i supposed to
assume that this is just a slip up and
not something more how can i make that
i'm telling i'm telling you it's not i'm
giving you a situation and i hear what
your situation is saying but i'm saying
as a man
i can't assume that that is the case i
have to assume that the answer is no you
wouldn't take her back no of course not
the thing
to take 100 because you know
because you should know that me slipping
up is literally just slipping up you
she's you letting a man in
it's not it's not because you said it
yourself you couldn't just let a man
slip into your tongue like that i said
me personally most women dating you i'm
always giving you a situation but if you
was dating me you can't slip up like
that i'm sorry i'm just giving you this
again
i'm saying i'm giving you an actual
scenario where she slipped up she went
on holiday she had a hot girl oh yeah
and then she just had a bit too much to
drink one thing led to another she just
one night stand oh i didn't it meant
nothing it was just a slipper but i
don't care
and then would you take her back
can i just say that women can i just say
that we're men she right when men she
it got no it's just it got nothing to do
with life i understand that when women
oh then when men she is a one-off when
women she the relationship is finished i
just can't do that
everything that you've i agree and 100
what i'm trying to say is that how many
women
are there if a woman cheats
she knows that the relationship is
finished
nine times out of ten if the woman
cheats that's the end of it that's the
end of her relationship that's true but
if a man cheats
it's not the end or to put it as my mum
will say it
men have all their bits on the outside
so they can fling it around everywhere
god hid the women's away because it's
hard to find internal so if you're gonna
go and give it away like that there's a
lot to go through for a man to get to
you internally rather just on the
outside because women are the
gatekeepers of sex or even more but even
more than that you have to think
but the point guys is like it's not
about the man which is coming back and
every time we know that he probably
gonna sleep around and come back home
the point is what about us like how do
we do you think that no actually you
know
has an impact on your marriage do you
think she gonna be fine
no knowing that you actually eat other
okay
are you sleeping
stop over talking me again again stop
over talking me
stop over talking me no no no stop stop
i'll you can go after i'm done okay
it men and women aren't the same and so
a man can have sex with a hole in the
wall they don't care a woman a woman if
she sleeps with some a man he has to be
someone we are not sleeping with bums
out there unless she looks like michael
b jordan that is it i get that but again
i'm like i asked everyone individually
would you get married and why i've asked
him individually would you take a woman
back if she slipped up and it was just a
one-and-done thing and it was michael b
jordan and it was like she had a chance
to would you take her back no no no no
but but if you did it and you slept with
a random whatever she can take you back
with a random american
woman i'm saying you as yourself i'm
asking as an individual not generalizing
okay so
should a woman take a man back if he
cheats no she shouldn't does she yes
that is not our choice
as we are saying men and women are
different
if you speak to women i've spoken to a
lot of women yeah and when they say to
me oh um my relationship ended because
my man was cheating yeah the first thing
i say to them is what did he cheat once
and then you left and they said no he
was cheating is never he cheated it's
always he was cheating which meant this
dude has decided he is going to continue
sleeping with other women but when did
she find out it was women it didn't find
out one and then it was oh no no no no
my point is
you are not going to go out and find a
woman who says
i went i was going out with this dude he
cheated on me once and i left
you don't it doesn't happen if women if
women don't like being treated why do
they pick the guys that cheat
exactly but even so yeah even so
on your point yeah
if i was to take this woman back do you
think she'll ever respect me
so she's going to go she's going to go
sit in the next man's face for banner
woman
if if you because you have to remember a
lot of relationships are predicated on
on respect yeah
if you've lost that respect for me
enough to step out
it's gone because you have to think
about in relationships the only time the
relationship's truly done is when the
woman says it's done
the man can say he's done and come back
a week later babes listen i'm sorry he's
dick's heart he wants to do something
you see when a woman says she's done
there's no return
end of end of so for a woman to do that
you might it's done
you're saying and for a man the most
egregious crime you can commit is is
disloyalty there's no there's no bigger
crime may i come back to your point you
said uh i never about you know our women
say uh he cheated once
yeah you're right because man doesn't
cheat one if it's if it's cheat one
we're gonna come back to again again
again so man doesn't cheat
once in a while or once in his life it
just if it is going down it gonna come
back
do you ever ask why he cheated
yeah because they know enough they know
in love no but i'm saying like a lot of
times like girls don't give their guys
sex and they're confused when they no
trust me trust me i've been there that
way
that wasn't okay okay twenty-five
percent of marriages are six
months
do you think sex for your husband is an
obligation so when he wants sex you can
give it to him
wait say again is sex in marriage or
relationship an obligation
no you should enjoy it obligation
every time he wants to bend you over are
you letting him put it inside you is
what i'm saying oh if you're married
or a relationship
honestly guys about feelings like it's
about what i'm saying and he seeks it
elsewhere
is that a problem you're going to say
yes but see but that's that's that's
messed up so then because you're because
you know what i'm saying i'm saying
because you're just thinking about what
you want
because
you're kidding if you want
because i've given it to you why i'm
going somewhere so because because
because a lot of times they have kids
with the girl i'm not so you're adding
stuff to the stuff okay
in the context of marriage yes that's
correct and the con context of a
relationship act called just bounce so
when you're married it's a difference
what are your what are your obligations
from a man
for you
in a relationship
what do you what do you want from a man
like what is he obligated to for you in
a relationship well i'm saying loyalties
up there trust loyalties up there that's
that's a must but then if you guys are
saying that
no no for you just obligation from a man
yeah just for you yeah just those two
things well that's one of them i can't
think and list them all up but yeah the
main one is loyalty and
to respect me love me all of that stuff
that's that's
up there that's well what if he says
i'm only doing that for someone that's
my wife i'll respect you then i'm out
you can't be loyal or respect me but you
want to be with me you only be
respectful and loyal to your wife
so then either you put a ring on this or
i'm gone that's it what if he said i'm
gone unless you give me sex on demand
i'm going as well then you're gone
what the hell what did you what if you
don't you don't think sex is a duty in
marriage but she just always my marriage
you're dating i'm confused like you keep
changing it it's marriage i'm usually
talking in the context of marriage but i
don't know i'm not married so i can't
say that i'm not married
i can't speak on marriage i've i've
never been married i'm not i mean i even
think in a relationship honestly if he's
not sleeping with anyone else yeah you
should give him sex whenever he wants
whatever he wants yeah
because like why should he go because
guys guys
guys want to [ __ ] all the time so if i'm
saying like please don't [ __ ] other
girls just [ __ ] me like then i should i
should i should get back
okay wait i together that but then if
there's just a one day where it's like
i'm not on it right now or i'm on my p
or whatever you're not using obviously
does that mean that he now has a right
to go and have sex with someone
obviously it's not one day come on let's
be let's be real about it like that's
that's what i'm saying but you guys are
making it sound i'll give you one day
not two i'll give you one day not deal
if you miss work one day they might give
you a pass of two days in a row
you might you might be getting a pink
slip
show us the scenario that you gave us
earlier about um you're you're messed
with your man yeah and work
i was about to say that yeah women
aren't feeling well
but they got all cold
they will still go to work
but if their man wants some sex they got
excuses for it they've got a headache
but they've never got a headache to go
to work yeah i mean if you're asking
me listen right
he's not giving you money yeah i mean
that's women you're dating up though
we're making the point like we're saying
that a man actually is going to cheat or
he's cheating because you didn't give it
enough
yes
it's like you're not showing up to work
and you're mad they gotta tempt while
you're gone
at least you're at least your job's
still there for when you get back
at least i didn't fire you just to tell
them
i just think that's a duty to have sex
with your man whenever he wants it
however he wants yeah
guys guys guys before we go again and
let's just reiterate some rules i know
we've got some new people on the panel
but guys one at a time i cannot hear you
they can't hear you please let's do this
say that again free up give them another
statement just say
the statement as far as i'm concerned we
may need to free up all the time andy
what if he wants what if he's at work
what should i do i'll drive to a
workplace
what if we're at the grocery store they
got taught in grocery stores
[Laughter]
what if we're at the library i don't
care that make no noise
what if we're at a concert listen i'm
taking it wherever wherever he wants it
i'm gonna be cooking i could be washing
that washing machine
what if you're on a podcast
if it's only fans i'm getting paid for
it yeah i'll have a go so
i just think you need to do it all the
time i have a question for you two
ladies because when auntie's talking
about that earlier she was talking about
it and we were like yeah if that's my
man if that's my husband why wouldn't i
youtube right now your facial expression
your body language is
when she's talking about it it's like
no i wouldn't do that if he wants it i
wouldn't do that all the time no no
if no but if if you want sex all the
time and that's your man or whatever
then fair enough have sex but the point
i'm trying to get at is
you could be giving him you could be
throwing it back do like you could be
giving it to him all day every day he
will still go somewhere else see someone
has the choice to cheat she's there and
i'll still have sex with her even though
my girl is giving it to me every day
okay live but life's nice
life's about trade-offs real life's
about trade-offs
no no but i'm saying so like i just i'll
explain so life is about trade-offs so
you can either pick a guy that other
women want and know he might cheat on
you or you can pick a guy that no other
women want and he won't cheat on you but
the thing is girls pick the guys that
other women want to bang he might cheat
but how would how would you know you you
you know and the thing is like girls act
stupid like no that no i'm not i'm not
i'm not talking about you i'm not
talking about you girls will act stupid
like they don't know this guy might
cheat
like but they know they know what like
you you can feel it on a guy if he gets
a lot of girls
honestly like if i can express my point
of view i wasn't like about uh the fact
if i love that man i will definitely
have sex with him whenever he wants
because i want it i want it
but if you actually if you actually
if you're actually talking about like
i have two
that's another point i don't have to i
want it it's different like in a
marriage it's supposed to be like that i
i've decide i want you because i love
you because there's something between us
not because you ask me that's one of my
duty which is different i don't have
duty for one day i'm sick and like i
just add that baby let's say
men like you know i agree with you i
agree with you do you know the problem
is i think a lot of women are quite
idealistic about future so a lot of
women think about as i am now in a
relationship when you've been there for
30 years your feelings and emotions
you and your woman having good sex and
she gets 20 years older 30 years older
she said no i'm too old she's talking
rubbish banger
right she's talking about rubbish